Roseann Ruthann. Pleasure to have you here. Thank you I'd like to
begin by quoting a line you haven't composed that I
really
love. It's kind of a line
to the poets you say
Someone once told me to perform to the six percent.
If the audience of the audience who are poets.
I have this in mind at some point. Every time I
sing but I often have to find that six percent by looking past
those who are your naming glazed
over
distracted and settled those who come to try
to look through me to see my
dad and those who can't respond to
music but like the experience of sitting in a
crowd with
those who can. Like you
to comment on this a little bit you know and I
might add by saying that on this very stage I once had Van
Cliburn and he said something not dissimilar he said he always
tries with his mom and dad's tremendously long
hands to reach out in the middle of the crowd of the audience of
the public to see how they are feeling how they are trying. How would how they
are
responding take the temperature. Yeah yeah that I do that show.
I. I sometimes imagine that if it's
not it's difficult to know if I'm late for going through mud or I
can't find the connector point. I
imagine pushing to the far rafters to the back
corners and. Coming back from there to try to find a way to connect I mean
it's not much of why that why the
poets wife or your wife write Yeah because they're listening.
The poets are left.
That's of such a good
response you know it's summer on a
Blackberry and then some are listening and it's generally the poets are those who have
a poetic spirit who are listening.
We just we just were in the rear book room in the big
collection. And you you wanted to
put your hands on what. The First Folio.
Of Shakespeare.
You know just just just to make just to make that clear
and on the specific passage.
Well I wanted to touch Henry the fests the
prologue where the narrator says he sets it up by saying Oh for
a muse of fire that would ascend the brightest heaven.
So I have that on my phone and I read it a lot just that while I
know from use of fire that what isn't the brightest talent I mean yes we all want
that don't sell I wanted to touch
that panel why did you want to touch that because why bad why that book
why there was something you really wanted to capture that moment with your
fingers because it's four hundred years of history in that
folio and all those Shakespeare himself wouldn't have touched it because it
was printed after his death his friend Ben Jonson probably
did touch it
so and when we came down the youth said to me
Ben Jonson
mayhaps touch up to you and you was
so excited. I can
feel my hair standing on the back of my neck just a talk. About it because he knew Shakespeare he was his friend
he wrote that beautiful ode to him in the front of the follow. So
and he
was you know hands on involved in creating the folio so maybe he touched
that one and you know four hundred years of history
and the original actor's names listed in
there were real people this is not some vague idea you
know it's a real thread. It's a real
threat. It's really something that is being
transmitted and it reminded me of a passage I often think about
of Henry James where he says I delight in the visit to Bill ten
Gibble
palpable powers. I delight in that.
I don't know if we have it here but if we do you will have you touch it you know
well
now you know there's another part about the past. Actually it's about
time I think it was Stuart Wilder he
said time is not a
river but a landscape that you step in and out of you
can move in a lot of directions and I
find. I find that to be true and.
Writing and
performing you find that to be true and true as time goes
by I do find that.
Creativity is bound to linear time I've always felt
that I'm not the first person to say that I
mean you know I wrote about it in
my book about getting postcards from the
future where we definitely will talk about those miracles from the future.
This isn't new agey stuff by the way when we don't like oh I don't like new agey
stuff. I don't think it is yeah no I mean I
agree with
you. More like in the realm of Blake
then Marion more.
Good
to know.
When we when we spoke briefly before before tonight I asked
you to put yourself
in
in a John Coltrane kind of frame of mind trying to.
To to evoke for me and for us tonight.
Some of your favorite thing.
And among my favorite things that I mean you were
going to go through a few of them to set the stage for other things we
might talk about I'd like to start by.
What you consider to be your favorite poem and then immediately told
me that's very end for many of us. But let's let's take a listen.
If we could
to wait.
I wrote this poem for a student who was thinking about suicide due to a love affair gone run.
It's called
Wait. Wait for now distrust everything if you
have to but trust the hours. Haven't they carried you. Everywhere
up to now. Personal events will become interesting
again here will become interesting pain will become
interesting but that open out of season will become interesting second
hand gloves will become lovely again their memories are what give
them the need for
other hand. And the does the lesson of lovers is the same
that enormous emptiness carved out of such tiny beings as we
are asked
to be filled. The need for the new love is faithfulness
to the
oh wait. Don't go too early
you're tired but everyone's
tired but no one is tired enough only wait a little
and listen to music of hear music of pain music of
looms weaving all their loves again. Be there to hear it it will be the
only time. Most of all to hear the flute of your
whole existence rehearsed by the sorrows play itself into
total exhaustion.
Had you ever heard him read it now that's beautiful girl awake you know.
Yeah well we can know.
What touches you that poem.
Wow the way he circles around to music to. All of the things
that
are musical that aren't music I love that
and I love him so that he gets to do
very mundane things you know hair will be interesting again pain will be interesting but
so will hair. The gloves
figure.
But also don't I mean given the context in which he wrote this poem.
Yeah we should not solidify the
moment right. You know
he does want of kindness in that
poem. You know to write it for someone who
was thinking of suicide
and
compassion and the name
of the poem it's just wait just wait
wait.
It reminded me of a.
Of a line of John Virgil ways this poetry can rip in no loss but it defies the
space which separates and it does this by its continual labor
of
reassembling what has been
scattered tat smart.
Among among the things that is that among the
things that you submitted to me as a
lift was this if we could watch video
number one I'd love you to tell
us why she mattered to you I don't know what you are you know
I
know you're going to look right there.
That's
a
very
rare
film.
There are scary
few performances of hers. That's Eleanor does.
Captured on
film and she was known and still is known as the
greatest actress of all
time. And she
was and. Gratian I mean when I was really young when I was in my
twenty's I just
was printed fascinated by that idea
of what made her the greatest actors of all time what did
she access. Not that she was acting that way.
What was she accessing. Knows even more than it
was how did she get herself out of the way
anough to access that thing that made her become the
greatest actress of all time and I went to acting school when I was young money. You
went to the lay person six months and I found out it was a very important lesson
I learned I found out I didn't want to be an
actor. And. It took me six months. You know I
probably knew after three but it
was great because I I found out about her and they showed
a couple of these
rare films I was the only one that yeah. This may be the only one
but there's another
scene you know there's another scene in the really I was on for a while but But what. What
did I mean when you see this I'm curious to push you a little bit. What what was it that
she access.
I don't know you don't know. Something that
is part of a mystery that that's why it's so
compelling to undo that mess. You really moves me
it. Well it moves
me
because she had to suffer to be able to do
that not the acting she has she has had to suffer
to get out of the way enough. You know and create a Whelan
herself deep enough to be able to do that just is you know that's why
Shakespeare moves me so much.
Not just that it's the most beautiful language ever written but that
the depth of the SOL that kids do I mean his facility with
language a spy. But the depth of the fall that could come up with
those characters in those stories in the deep understanding. I mean when
I can't fall asleep at
night I I have this. You know how you have
a a senior go to that comfort you to help you fall asleep.
I was going to always tell me you don't have an idea. You know what I want you to tell me because you
know right now I'm going to work for you this is when I saying OK but lately maybe you can share it.
What is your well I'm happy to tell you
because it won't stop working because it just won't. So I
imagine Shakespeare being rowed across the
Thames from the globe on the South Bank to the master of the
rebels'
office
on the other bank in what's now is lying
to
him and taking his manuscript of Hamlet up
to get permission to stage it. I just
go over her spokesperson. And then you Paula see.
I think everything makes sense and. He had to
get permission to stage Hamlet. OK I you know everything
makes
sense.
So I told you this this Coltrane moment
I ask.
Roseanne to give me some of her favorite moments
and she started it and then she simply didn't
stop. For the past ten days or two weeks
I've gotten things I've
gotten more and more and more things that she
loves I'm afraid I would still leave something out.
Yes And also it just showed an appetite and
so will begin with a collage if we could begin with image one and we'll go through
the twenty nine images.
Fairly quickly.
So that was a collage of the things you love and now if we could go to two.
And you can just comment on them as we go in
on site for Monday.
Well. He reminds me of myself as
a child for some reason and the good part of childhood and I
love that it's roses. So I like a
theme.
Let's let's move along with it will make it will make a symphony and
then.
Offer explanatory.
OK let's let's
continue
our that's an inspiration. A lot of my
sewing circle powers that are here tonight. I I'm in a sewing
circle and we're all inspired by the woman who created this her name
is Natalie Chan and could look at the next
image and there is Natalie.
And she's a goddess she has a mission she all of these calls are hand stitched she's put all of
these women to work who used to work in the textile industry and were out of jobs and
they can take a kid home and they make these beautiful clothes and I
wear them on stage that's all I wear and
we are all fans of Natalie so we get together in this whole room.
Yeah it's
a lot of money so many people if they come out all my stuff I want
you to know. Well my role is in the brand I don't know why are you going to the whole sewing team
if you and
but yeah.
But she she said something to you
about we've read well.
I went down there for a workshop in Florence Alabama. So she could teach me to
sew John my husband went with me and she
was threading my needle and she does this thing where she pulls the
threads with first finger tips until the two strands
lined up like soldiers. She
says. They become smoother as you struck them and John was taking a little I feel.
Video of our hands of her showing me doing this and she said her
great accent she says you have to love this thread you have to learn to love the
thread not doing your accent very well and she was
speaking literally but I heard it as a metaphor.
When she said it and I was writing a father's not a
bird and I just put it right you have to learn to love the
thread. And it took a
very big meaning for me. So every time I get together.
Sewing group.
Threads with each
other and.
Look.
I
know
I.
Lawyer
who
day
at
one
point
by
one
on one I.E.
no one
bought by a little
a leg to I Why.
Tell us a little bit
about this. That song is about my grandmother
my grandparents on my dad's side were cotton farmers
tenant farmers in the New Deal in the Works Progress
Administration colony called Dyess colony in the sunken lands
of Arkansas and it's called the sunken lands because the
land bank in an earthquake of eight hundred
eleven and my parents my grandparents
were desperately poor so they were one of the five hundred
families who were accepted to live in this
colony and it saved their lives and my grandmother.
I
just I'm involved with Arkansas State University in restoring that
house out of the five hundred thirty left and my dad's boyhood home was one of
them and creating a music heritage site and also the new deal you
know people don't really pay attention to the New Deal was an
enormously important part of our history when socialism worked in this
country and save their lives so I just thinking
about my grandmother and how incredibly difficult her life
was you know she didn't have electricity in the first
decade or so. She raised seven
children she picked cotton. My grandfather was not a
nice man and she suffered silently gave birth at home with an aspirin.
You know and. I
just kept thinking I am a modern woman I live in New York City I
have every a minute reacted want to help. But what is it of
me that comes from her of there must be something. What is spread
what is a threat and I I think it's her tenacity.
You know she never gave up. I don't give up.
The
slums you look at I get a little scared like no no no no oh.
Well you know you just said that you had tenacity DON'T GIVE UP I'M NOT YOUR let's look at a few more
images if we could got thrown away my
shot. Thank you.
So we we can move to image
five.
That's a painting of Joan of Arc. Which is at the Met. I've gone and
looked at that painting a million times you noticed the angel
in the trees or.
It didn't turn out well for
her
to be bad.
But she was connected to transform kind
of transcendence right. So it didn't turn out well for her but I think you can be
connected to something transcend it and have it turn out well. So she's a
cautionary tale but it's beautiful.
And
in no particular order you just sent them to me
like things. Well you know Delta Blues.
Call connect. Well it's a coconut cake. My
daughter had this little cooking show online called Big City grits
she lived in Brooklyn but she cooks other of food and.
It was adapted from my grandmother's recipe and then my one of my oldest friends
got involved and so the recipe the three recipes from the three
women morphed into one coconut cake and I said that that
I insist that people eat coconut cake at my
funeral.
Somebody please write that down who is younger than me so I'll be here through mine he paused.
So you could write it
but you know it's it's said that as a joke but I I
think to some extent
you.
It's not that you're thinking about that moment. But some of the experiences you
had in
the region visiting certain places you
were thinking about what it would have felt like say for your mother or your
father to be there in the presence of your son to have
been present to a
moment that they no longer experienced and hear about talking about this
cake in some sense you're you're preparing something for the future now in
the present that you would like to see happen that you may not witness to know what
you will
know you just made me think of something I have this picture of myself
there two years
old sitting on the front porch of the house I
was born in
Memphis and there's a very poor neighborhood but the house is still there exactly as it
was and I have this picture. Two
years old so when the album right before the album came out.
Yes this morning.
Took me down to Memphis to do this thing about the river and the thread my last
record and you know tracing the past in Memphis nary thing. So I went to the
house set an exact same spot.
Exact same position as I was at two. So I have those two. And I have
a third space. So I can go back when
I'm eighty. And have
Austria.
So I'm preparing something for the future.
Postcards it.
Samuel Pete.
I have an obsession with Samuel peeps. He you
probably know he was the greatest
diarist English Tyrus ever and so much of what we know
about the seventeenth century in England is because he kept a diary every
day he witnessed the Great Fire of London. He was there in the restoration.
As a boy he thought King
Charles executed but it's not all of that that's fascinating.
It's
about he cheated on his wife. He's made an
arm a promise to himself he's going to give up the wine and going to the theatre but he
doesn't he breaks
it and he is incredibly honest with himself about his four balls
and his strengths and his pride and how much money he's made any gets a new
watch and he he described a scene where he keeps taking the watch out of
his pocket to look at it and I think well that's what you do when you get a new i Phone You know he
does you know some things don't change and there's this one passage.
Where he says just as I wrote this.
The Crier went by with the lantern and
said. It's two am a frosty night. This is just as I
wrote this so it's almost like the visceral quality and that
is still thrilling press. Yeah. So I signed up for his
news e-mail
blast
and he has thank you once every
day I get a diary entry every
day by e-mail from Sandy I'm from the same
day like and sixteen forty sixteen sixty but for
this day so I got you know tonight I'll get April nineteenth.
Sixteen fifty eight.
I know I thought Oh OK my touch and goes deeper than that PA
so I went to London to find the church that he belonged
to there it is St Olaf
and. It's basically the same they boarded up one door
from the back. But there's three skulls over the in tree way
into the yard and he lived across the
street so he would go there and he was. You know a little self-important he was in
the Navy office so there was a Pew that was just for the
Navy officers or not he was an officer he worked in the
Navy
office. Anyway I could go on forever about this I went down on
the credibility. It's interesting to me also because of your attachment
and reverence for pilgrimage to go I take older men yes
you do
P.M.S.. Yeah I definitely do you know I went to the library and having a word and having you up in
the in the rib look in the in the book collection.
I could tell you I mean this
is this is and this is an electrical charge
yeah something happens when you're you're in the presence of the. Place and the space.
I mean the sewers empty space you're living in the in the house you
mentioned the you're going there
because you want to be we he
was.
Yeah and has his
books. You know he created a beautiful library over time
and he willed his library to his nephew and his nephew gave it to Magdalen
College in Cambridge because because peeps went to Cambridge.
So you can go to the Peep's library they recreated it exactly and I went there too.
And I was becoming an unhealthy obsession
to
another. More recognisable obsession.
Just as much as peeps if not more.
And
your father had them sign. Yeah I still have their autograph.
Well I mean you know who else had that done this Costello's father.
I know this. Yeah some cop you have that in common.
Well I love Alyssa decent history my friend Sean tall who's here she and I
trade books all the time about the latest Elizabeth and history books as if something's
going to
change
but
you never know you can't just turn oh we're
going to find some little grain of you know. Anyway
I mostly about Shakespeare because
I yeah you know fits into that yeah. Next one and.
Oh it's
Myra grateful grateful grateful. Myra
common and she just inspires me so much. Talk
about culture and the way she thinks and paints is very much like Coltrane and
her
Schumer the lovely Myra. And I have you saw
the
painter a painting that I have is so filled with joy. Right because
Lloyd the joy and it serves a purpose
that joy in
that you know which one I have right there in the bounty is table the table laid out
with all of the food handouts and yes. I don't know how
to do that very well so I look at that to inspire me don't know how to do what
well relax into barren tea.
I know how to
work and. Look for inspiration but that kind
of bounty is sometimes
fields
where I don't know maybe I don't have enough gratitude for
it it's what you know what you were mentioning in that
same passage of T.-Bone Burnett telling you
stop worrying but keep
working stop worrying keep working. Well I don't do that.
Oh sorry. Oh you know. This is this drug in
my ribs work this joy and there's also the other side of
joy right confusion.
Right she's a person who goes straight to the obituaries when she's reading the paper and I like to do that too.
I like so do Why yes why do why I mean that's because a bitch worries and not about
about the
same well except I like to read about plane crashes why what I'm for
I like
to do. Yeah. What will you say well that's
a misnomer that was
meddling testing go back to that that was this is my favorite
interior designer Madeline Castaic she was a French woman she was crazy she
would just take broken down chairs and put them in the apartment
was some you know fabulous something and her colors were
all of green. Black and French blue.
So you can't really see it there but you can.
So that Mandler and I bonded over Madeline conspiring to
we were at dinner with some other women and somehow it got on to design and.
One of us mentioned Mallika staying and we both like you know who she
is because she's not that famous.
So anyway. That's MY has
been tuning my guitar during a
performance. This.
Mariachi
for the greatest cheese fallen in the
world. You know I have to have three cups
in the morning to do you know that TS Eliot drank forty cups of tea a day
I did not but I do know.
Yeah
I should
call.
His he just inspires me. He's his sense
of fantasy and beauty.
Did you see the should call show when he was was. At the Jewish Museum two years ago.
I don't believe.
That's
Lawrence Olivier with the skull that
his performance of Hamlet is I think one of the
greatest performances of all time.
It's
you.
But I don't let's. Let's play if we
could hold your number three. I would see.
By
now
I'm
not
Sally
come nigh I am still one
a
man noname
gone
and
beyond
the game
listed in the BT
news
story. Of you speaking to your
father and you didn't have the Bible with you.
And you only had Shakespeare and he said we'll
speak tomorrow.
So in the last few weeks of his life he like it lost a sigh.
And he liked to be read to
so they mostly liked the Solve to be read the
songs and
I would read them when I was down visiting him and I would read in the Psalms and then when
I got home he wanted to hear them on the phone so
I call and read in the Psalms and then I went up to the country forgot to
take me to spy Bible and I only had Shakespeare there. So he
said let's wait as said dad and so sorry I didn't bring it you know can I read
you Shakespeare and he said
oh this wait and this song that we just heard is
the. I
really well that's really my record Black Cadillac which was written
after my parents died and my step mother and they
all and my stepsister they all died in a two year
period and I woke up in the
night writing that
song and I couldn't get the chorus you know I was doing really well
with the
verses and then it was Christmas time my dad died and September was Christmas.
I still hadn't written the courses and I took my kids
to St Luke's in the village to the
Christmas Eve services they went to school at St
Luke's So if I ever go to church once every five years I
could have St
Luke's and they saying that him was
were leading still proceeding and I went.
That's it and I just took those lines and put them in my song. I
figured that it was so obvious that I had stolen them that no one
would complain and nobody
nobody has the right hasn't so much to do you know I always
thought that that was not a great vocal because I.
I hear all my old stuff I start breaking it down into parts you know the sessional
who's playing well and not I we had been recording for twelve
hours and it was close to midnight when I did that vocal so
ever since and I thought I sound tired but you know we
kept it but it sounds pretty good.
You know we're going
to thank you. I'm not. Thanks. We're going to skip
over some images that just maybe show them in quick succession. If we can show the images in quick
succession because I have so many other things I want to talk to you about. But here's some of the
other favorite things.
Jane Austin huge
fan. All about
is one of my favorite movies of all time. So Bette Davis.
The
Globe
and French antique linen which. I'm
going to. I'm going to the south of France with some of the ladies in August
and plan on buying a lot of
that
Mark Rylan my favorite actor. I went
to London to see
him play. Richard the third at the globe. And with my friend Sean
tall and at the end I burst into tears. It was so
moving and then he brought it to Broadway I went to see it again on
Broadway is. Amazing
experience.
So starry eyed that was.
I'm really sorry it's sure not that funny to most people but
it's I like creating impel playing grabs a hold up in my mind because I fly
so much. It's some kind
of superstition dead. If
I you know if I put it right in front of me it'll never happen.
That's a terrible picture I didn't know you were going to use
that blood diamonds.
I
like medical mystery. I like medical novels and
medical memoirs in fact I'm reading the iceberg.
And if you read that Marion quotes about her husband's last two years of his
life with a brain
tumor. And you know I had
a really serious brain condition and had brain surgery and ever since
then I just like reading things like that particularly if they figure it
out they figure out which for us.
But you got one before having the brain surgery you really spent a lot of
time researching and trying to figure things
out right because I couldn't find a doctor who would tell me what was wrong.
Let's
see who is this guy that.
Well you know every songwriter who works in the tradition. I work
and owes a debt to Bob Dylan. There would be none of us
without Bob Dylan was great to show you some of his
material Thank you.
That is on the headstock of my
guitar.
And I've got a custom Martin guitar they made it for me it's called The Roseanne Cash model not to be
to protect it's about it
but and it's an O.M. twenty eight which is smaller than
a drug not are mine and I asked
him to put a rose on the headstock and. They had never done that before
but
apparently Green had never been on a Martin guitar and it's you know
one hundred fifty year history.
So all of the guitar geeks kind of freaked out when they saw the big screen on the
head start. I love that.
That's
me
coming off stage. I like the moment when it's
over with when the OK.
Now doesn't mean I don't love what I'm doing. I like that moment
when. I don't know it. And
you like the moment before it's
my When you metabolize it. Yeah but I like that moment when it metabolizes
at the end there's two of my kids.
Some. These are some of your your favorite things now.
Quite firmly you said to me I guess we will have to talk about
my
father. And.
I obviously want to talk about the context of your upbringing and
you sent me one photo.
Yeah I didn't write this in July. Yeah he sent me one photo and I would like you to tell
me everything you possibly see in that
photo. It's a remarkable photo.
Number thirty.
Well I was born in Memphis and that's me on my dad's
lap when you're you when you're old that was one year old.
And he sent you that photo because
it's not about.
Miss It's not about a Miss Right.
It's
real this
is just a family photo my dad was taking me to the zoo.
And that was
before I mean he made its first
record.
The year before like right around when I was born
and but the intense touring hadn't
started. He wasn't on drugs.
My parents were still together. It's not that I have some you
know rosy fantasy about how I was in and long for I really
don't but
that that's important to me because it hasn't been
co-opted by the
public to that moment. It
hasn't been he hasn't yet as you said he has not yet become
super
famous or. You're not yet at
that moment in your life are you hearing everybody else. Considering
him. God night. Yeah that's well put.
I love that description you have of him coming to a
kindergarten class. That's a great story. So my daughter Chelsea was
in kindergarten and they wanted grandparents to come in to
say what they
did.
What they
had. So.
My dad was came in to Chelsea's kindergarten class and he got up in front of the
kindergarten there are a few parents and there are not
many. He gave
this unbelievable little talk
that was the history of American roots
music from like that it was in a five year old you know understanding and
he just let it through and this mother Lynn told me she cause somebody
should film this is unbelievable this you know this should be recorded for
history. It's going yeah I mean it was really good really
concise and then at the end this kindergartner raised their hand and they
said can you duck
walk
the greatest part is my dad said Well I believe I can and he
touched him. Michael Jackson's across the
tour.
But what I mean is that so many parts of this story which are great and part of them
are part of what strikes me so much is that you saw
there in your
father someone who just knew so much about history.
He was a musicologist and really had a sense of.
Cred issue and you know I told you that in Hebrew the word for Christian and transmission of
the same. Yeah. And he so deeply believed in that that
he did he like I said he had the mind of a musicologist and he
had categories of songs that he could put you
know songs about Appalachian songs about mother. Oh yeah I know forty of those and he could
sing them all to songs about dead dogs. Yeah I got those
two songs about travel songs about longing for
home. And then he gave you. I mean this
grand moment he gave you and that's going to ask you to bring it but then I thought
maybe better for you to describe it. He gave you this list.
Yeah. When I was eighteen he made a list of songs hundred
hundred songs.
What he called a hundred essential country songs but there really it
was broader than country music it was.
American songs you know there were protests songs and there are history
songs and.
So I saved the list you know I had the good sense to say the list I was eighteen.
I made a record based on the list after he died. Took songs from the list.
If you had to make a list like
that. For your children I
am.
There's some overlap. You know but I grew up in a different generation.
So I would have Beatles and I'd have been the all young and I'd have Dylan.
But.
There's the big overlap with my dad Swiss for sure you know.
Hank Williams Long Black Veil all those kinds of songs.
It's like take a listen to five the engineers dying child which is
the engineer's dying child. Why did you pick that one. I don't know.
A
little
bit
all the sick bed lay and this was really
nice he was the pride and
the judge ruled
in
his duty had called him the love.
And seeing that hole was
there while a tear he shed too is
why he said just to lead you astray and
I'm just saying a lot when I
still hang it where it
can be seen if the ME because
they then show the red if he's better
than the green.
He loves that falling. And it's you know there is a tradition
in Appalachian music particular singing about into mortality was so
high there were a lot of songs about losing babies. So this one is particularly poignant
because the engineer has to go to work and he
leaves the
baby mortally ill. So he tells his wife when the train goes
by our
house is the baby's dead. Hang the Red Lantern
innocent babies that are hanging the Green
Lantern You don't hear that on top forty radio
anymore.
And that's I think in part what he wanted
to impart this love and
the songs yeah and I got it.
I mean you say saying yes. You say traditions can
take root out of the dormant impulses of one soul this is at the very end
of composer.
If they are powerful enough for that we acknowledge them or not
I finally had the with them and grace.
Not only to acknowledge but to review of them and
embody them with the
real joy.
That's so true and it took me a while
but. I was in Dublin a few years
ago I was walking down the street and there was a beautiful little antique
bookstore and I went in and there was this
enormous book on the
shelf the sick and it said it was a music book history of
Irish music so I pulled it down and it fell
open to a drawing.
And said John Cash. In it was a minstrel from
the eighteenth forty's and he was carrying a
melodeon it's still open to take and it
was
so chilling and then I didn't buy the book because it was four hundred
pounds for four hundred euros and you just get four hundred euros come
on but never for I took a picture of the page
on never ever forget that moment. And it was as if it was
saying you know you well done last keep doing it.
He
said he made other lists and I have one that I very
much like if you could True Image That's
one. Yeah.
I kept thinking oh I have something better I have it framed in
my my check cave called my chick cave.
As opposed to a man case. It says
Tuesday under
no circumstances will I talk to anyone in the music or film business
today.
That's good
advice.
You see he told. You have to be the template of how to be an artist.
They are the father you write provided a template for me of how to live
with integrity as an artist today.
He taught me to respect my
audience and a lot of the integrity isn't in that as a
performer. You know I said never
forget which town
you're in never forget that people have used their heart and their own dollars to
buy a ticket to come see you.
You know show up on
time show up when you're performing really show up be
there be there.
Yeah out so that has its own integrity and
then ruthlessness as a
writer you know that's a separate integrity.
You say in
your eulogy you described him as a Baptist was so.
Of a mistake.
So I love God with the means.
He didn't
judge and even though he was deeply spiritual It
just didn't fit into he said it was a Baptist but I didn't see that as fit into that you
know has he had too big of a consciousness about spirituality.
Let's take a listen to what you six are winding
stream me. Now.
To me singing streams
not
to needing
to leave to stream.
Yeah
this
i
first
thing this when he was dying this is the
last song I said to you two things. I couldn't.
That's a Carter Family
song and those were the first songs I learned on
guitar the Carter family was on the road with my dad and
their hours in the dressing room backstage and so the women
June Helena needed Maybelle Carter. They taught me all the
songs and that's really where my love began for
these Auld. Roots in traditional songs and he liked to hear me sing
that when I see much of his wife I say
no and a few
others but that
was you know he was gone after I sang that
song. Singing together for example when it comes
to number seven.
There's
a
little
full
chat
on
playing
the
evening
first
thing.
Many
of
us
left
so
I
told
him to. The
hard way.
Roseanne just said that she had something to play for us.
Because I said I had something to say but all the
way into this room. Thank
you thank you
where things can happen. Well I don't want to play that song I just nodded but no
idea where I was going to
say that. That
that was recorded not too long before my dad died.
And I took to get down to Nashville so he could record.
His part I recorded my part and.
He was not feeling well at all and like I didn't know that morning in fact that he was going to be
able to do it but he said he read the lyrics and he said I can I can do this you know we went over to the
studio and he sang it I could see him getting in a G. as he started
singing you
know and he said. Now you take that back to New York
and if it's not good enough that John doesn't think it's good enough I'll do it
again said dad. It's so good
and I was so sweet. There's even in that moment.
You know has this integrity.
You know he goes he says about you in his autobiography said
Roseanne and I operate on much the same wavelength. So there's always been a
special closeness between us.
It's not a matter of deeper love or good than between me and the girls
it's about like a greater degree of instinctive
understanding. I would say that's true.
Let's play something that's never been played before you might want to set that up a little
bit you you you let New York know today that Jerry would they
would be hearing something out of the vaults that has
never I wonder I was wondering if you and I were mad about
that now. Oh good OK well I wasn't mad at all I would have
been upset if I hadn't gotten to it.
When
I was recovering from brain surgery it was a long recovery and I was not
feeling well and. I laid on the
couch for a long time like a year and I was just one
day laying there and I just saw this image of me and
Elvis Costello and Kris Kristofferson together doing
something recording something image number thirty two friends and they're
both close friends and that I had never thought about the three of us at the.
And any sense to me but I anyway I emailed Elvis I said do you want to riot
and song together and then John in the
background. And if Chris wants to join shall we do this song together
and he goes yeah.
So I A Chris doesn't do email but I emailed Lisa and they were his
wife
and they were both into it.
So we looked at our calendars and it turned out that April
first
two thousand and eight was the only day. Within a two year period that the three
of us would be in New York City at the same time you wrote the song the song
A profits which you're not going to play now that it's on
Elvis's the CD that just came out with his memoir. So we got to
the studio. I had written a verse Elvis had written a burst nothing from Chris we
were so worried we get to the studio. Chris writes his verse we record the
song that day.
It's beautiful. We couldn't think what to call it so we called it a process. So it had never come
out but. Elvis just put it out with his memoir with the CD and we were so happy.
So same
day we wrote another song I had started
it
and send it to all the same thing. Chris shows up slow.
We've also finished the song that day recorded it and it's been in
the vaults and two thousand and eight. It's never come out but Alpha's email me just a few days
ago and he said what are we going to do about the song. Some people should hear eight gods
of Harlem and now they will.
Yeah first go let's
go
next. Banking hall
Gomez but they don't know going
to going to be.
The
legality
of the
grid a little girl
and
children
bomb
bomb bomb bomb
bomb. Nothing wrong with
the dog saw it come
and gone
blow it in Girl with
the Airbus plane.
Chris is the
bomb in a living
beyond its
chair Chris is just
beyond bomb.
A guy had to push
hard
to get lawyers who didn't live there existed the band to
play in it she lives it
is sad to
say to him live pain
and pleasure. Herr
Earl Neil Lennon marry your
Mrs gained a good prayer millionaire and a big
serious brain it turned out to name the
place and a place down
a good feeling in the hind limbs am
using
P.S. the best chance missed the renminbi
myth a news you need in
your room to slowly indeed limp old
a limited old Polonia great disdain
bomb been made against the
am
thankful we are slowly wind
down this question comes to
to me for you from Elvis Costello.
So I asked him yesterday and he does do email thankfully said
I suppose I'm beginning with the statement. Rather than a question but. I think
the list contains some of your most beautiful
singing and this seem to add another dimension to your vocals on
the river in this thread. Given that singing other people's song
is usually where we
begin. I'm curious to know. Ruth if
contemplating any one song on the list also opened
up some new musical or lyrical possibilities within
your songwriting.
Well
in general the standard of songwriting is so high on the list
that it's it motivating in a challenge and you know it's something
to to reach for and to try
to you know pop up your game to I'm never going to
write I'm So Lonesome I Could Cry that's written but it's
it's inspiring.
Singing long black veil. I think that
that's. It's such plain language and
it's so it's full of ghosts and it's a very dark story
that I would say is some songs on the river in the
thread are cousins to long but they're all in that way cousins. Yeah.
You know I I feel
that you're. There's a lot
of songs are complete somewhere else
and that you can pull them down
sometimes in there depending on your level
of skill and how hard you work to just been
disappointing yourself and refining your skills you can pull down better songs you know
I want
to I'm never going to get Bob Dylan songs or drill. I want to indicate I want to and.
I want to end with this image thirty three we could.
It
is a song always presses me brings back such sad memories. You know what I
mean I've never heard another song that depresses me the way this one
does play it again will you and I asked
you
tonight to end our
evening on a moment of joy and I remember
you has been saying that's a deal breaker.
Yet we always hear we don't do Joy.
Actually after most of our songs you know people
want to sort of put an end
to their lives and you. You said you might try.
Well I had to call my manager and say Do I have any songs that even
slightly resemble Joe
I so let's see
now during.
The Well. Should I Do you
know. Anything you guys want to hear
in particular.
Seven
Year A is that you think
projectable
some are echoing you know.
Now. OK wait here's some.
Think river in the
thread and it's got a course that you could sing along to actually and
so you'll know where that it falls so I'd prefer it if you
would the line that you'll sing along to is.
Fifty thousand watts of Common Prayer and that comes
from there's a radio station in Memphis called W D I A and
their slogan is fifty thousand
watts of goodwill. And I loved
that but I thought you know if you've been changed by something you've heard on the radio there are a lot of
us who've wives have been changed by something we heard on the radio and so
we're a community and that's a common prayer and this is called fifty
thousand watts
of common
for
the mud from budget to
Sheila's
shoot
dawn of rooms
I'm rough rule the
food
down the love of God
still closed the
deal
yet the thing is broken and painted in smooth.
There's a lot old
Sunday the New World is Nigh and.
The sound of the live so-called Leweni all
the mud in your future awaits you use that
out with fifty thousand watts of a common
phrase
to it. And now
the common thread that was your part
of this system lots of
the common in the whole we
are not who we
will
just do the
hand rather
to
live like
he was in
the
region all
Kong just to
know
this is a lad only
Sunday
he said don't was so close reading
over love and huge a way to
you with fifty thousand watts of
a comma.
And with you go. This
and unload to the palm
of
his fist of all those palm not comma
with this in
the hole. Thanks.
Thank you you know I was really nervous about this because there's no
fourth wall
but it turned out well I like talking to you
Paul thanks
so much of a do forty one.
Seven
Your.
OK I wrote this song when I was younger than
my youngest daughter
and good at thirty five years ago
and I just got the copyright back last
month back selection for
young songwriter Do not give your copyrights away takes a very long time to come
back
you will learn
tonight and in the movie
feeling blue below you pass along to
the baby room
sing assuming you will soon the girls in the
love stand live.
They will sing and when the telling news.
You look so careless solution to nobody
except
the room. Tell me.
Randy
killed the world
to going to win the gold.
If the body
belongs to the Tim
the victim
him didn't do you still
shoot if you wish to breathe in the house sleep in it
and then he has the bomb
why did you not
of don't ponder on the use of these
and this is true on him it pulled the venue Channing
is
a dealer
to one of
the girls take out a
little movie called A year
and a little
do a little
unnerving
to
revive her.